mandam used to turn it into a game black
growing up it used to be like oh like
you know the whole Mr Studio girl like
stuff like that yeah I remember a person
who remained nameless
they were out and then they secured the
girl on the night out or the lady I
should say
and gone to the car
she's glogging him off doing a throat
business in the car
um the husband's called it's just like
I'll pick you up
she's finished off the guy and then
she's got and picked up by me wow and
she drove home she's happy satisfied
this is crazy oh my God women are
that's interesting do you think men
cheat as bad
not as bad because men are sloppy like
if your man's cheating you probably know
deep down you probably know that he's
cheating yeah like women always have a
hunch exactly I would agree to that yeah
would you would you guys be willing to
share a guy if if he had everything you
wanted he loved you but just now and
then he would step out
arrives
me and Jess are on a two-for-one special
get it while you can yeah Sister Wives
did you actually do that
no no
no
you might I might okay why tell me why I
don't
I think monogamy is very hard I think
long term man and women so you took an
open relationship are you talking about
on his end
um it would have to be both oh it'd have
to be enough yeah
could you still because a lot of a man
we've had the conversation before a man
can love a woman and throw his Willy
about and fall into vagina from time to
time but a lot of women they can't do
that so would you could you say that you
could still love the guy you're with and
still be open in a relationship in my
mind
I think after a certain amount of years
5 10 maybe 20 years yes in the beginning
early phases I don't think
I could because that possessive like
need to claim is there but I think
eventually I imagine this is how I
imagine After Time
I probably could
probably be a bit bored I imagine he
would too would you be willing to do it
where it's it's open on his end but not
yours no I feel like that's what the
terms would usually be if he's providing
and stuff like that yeah if he's
providing okay
how many relationships are like just the
man providing
no but this is isn't that the scenario
you presented oh yeah yeah yeah so if
he's providing well then yeah I'd
probably have to put up with it but
um 8 000 fun fact 8 000 years ago 17
women reproduced for every one man
yeah so we can't we can't do biology 8
000 years ago 17 women reproduced
strawberry one man that's a fool
wow so Amanda demanda want to go back in
time but now with the population getting
so out of control surely it would make
sense to reverse that so so actually
there's there's
um there's probably gonna be problems in
society because of population decline
actually people aren't having kids why
because okay think about it
um if you don't have enough people in
the Next Generation to fill jobs then
that that leaves a gap in society
what jobs are not being filled well
right now
um I want to say the medical industry is
low on like that doctors and I don't
know specifically I just know that one
of the biggest like causes of
civilizations like collapsing is a
population decline when you think about
yeah like overpopulation is good for an
economy
yeah when you look at um Japan because
they've got an aging population they've
got to a point of because they've got
um less young staff coming into work
they've got state fund fueled pensions
but there's so many pensioners and
there's not enough Workforce oh okay so
you've just got a lot of people living
on the state and not enough people
paying into the state so why are young
people not going into the workplace what
is that no just people having kids
anymore yeah why are they not having
kids they can't afford it they don't so
um I would say it's because of hypergamy
do you know what hypergamy is so
hypergamy is the action of marrying or
forming a sexual relationship with a
person of a superior sociological or
educational background women date across
and up hierarchies so essentially when
birth control was introduced it gave
women the option to sleep around so when
that happened basically a smaller and
smaller percentage of men were sleeping
with all the girls so if you ask a
hundred percent of women what they want
in a guy they list 20 percent of men
sometimes less so if you want a guy
that's over six foot that's only 15
percent of guys
you want to be good looking cut it in
half you want them to make money cut
that in half right so basically when
that happened
um I think it let fours fives and sixes
in terms of like looks sleep with guys
that are eights nines and tens and think
they're on that level and then think
anything below it is settling
okay
so as women's rights and freedom have
progressed relationships of regress yes
so yeah yeah we need to either step down
how do we get out of this
everyone instead of having children yeah
I mean I think it's just
like we're just in a society where women
a lot of women are delusional okay okay
because what's your level right anyone's
like level one to ten it's what you can
get to commit to you it's not what you
can sleep with and I think a lot of
times women like confuse the two and so
they'll they'll [__] on average men like
like that's why we have in society we
have
I don't want no scrub like
but we don't have I don't want no whales
I don't want no fat chicks like like
they would be canceled immediately
and so everything in society it's weird
once you see it you cannot see it it's
like everything in society is empowering
women and pushing women forward and so
it it makes us narcissistic almost
because we think the whole world
revolves around us
but the same thing of what empowers you
also makes you blind because even though
you think you're being empowered but
then when you're not getting wiped by
the man that you want and he goes into
the real wild world and you realize I'm
actually very regular degular I'm
nothing special
okay but what class of women are you
talking about like how intellectual are
they where do they come from what are
women or you think all women think like
this most women yeah
you get the dating app data which allows
women to be very honest and women only
swipe right five percent of the time
they're not ugly in pictures though no
women find 80 no no women find 80 of men
unattractive not uh okay like
unattractive but what about in person no
just anywhere anywhere yeah eighty
percent of men they find unattractive
because I've spoken to them or because
on face value that like there's
something chemically that they're like
because they've had better sexually and
they're just their standards are skewed
so yeah so a lot of a lot of times I'll
hear girls say things like oh he's
medium ugly and I'm like no sis that's
your level
but but you know that term you've heard
it right oh you've never heard Medium
you're not on social media right
Snapchat
there's only 20 of men are actually
having sex 20 yeah so one out of one out
of three men either are virgins or
haven't had sex in the past year
and that's the trend so that's the trend
that's going going on the last like 50
years where it's like 50s yeah slowly
it's a bigger and bigger percentage of
men aren't having sex so but if most
women are having sex that means they're
having sex with the same guys
that's like why do you think women say
things like men are trash all men cheat